une conférence de presse s'est tenue ce
mercredi 21 octobre au palais de la
source pour le lancement de la 18e
édition du challenge des créateurs
cette opération initiée par le conseil
départemental récompense les meilleures
initiatives en matière de création
d'entreprise cette année encore six
nouveaux chefs de très petites
entreprises se verront récompensés par
la collectivité et ses partenaires en
bénéficiant de plusieurs raisons peuvent
alors offrir la possibilité de
bénéficier de 100 heures de formation
gratuite
zéro également un accompagnement pour
l'établissement de leur déclaration
fiscale
si jamais ils commettent deux
des erreurs ont leur signalera s'ils
oublient de bénéficier de l'exonération
est que ça on aperçoit évidemment leur
dira aussi si jamais ils pourront
également comparer leurs chiffres avec
leurs concurrents savoir où ils se
situent alors évidemment c'est une
comparaison anonymes eux mais ça permet
de savoir où je me situe et puis comme
ça pendant deux trois ans aussi avoir
des sites des graphiques très simple qui
permet de se situer et de savoir
l'évolution qui a sur des indicateurs
économiques et financières alors c'est
une aide qui nous semble indispensable
pour un créateur d'entreprise il nous
semble assez difficile de se retrouver
dans les méandres de
pas sûr de moi social est ce que je sais
on s'était dit qu'il serait bien que
l'on commence par une journée
d'information collective sur le web
quelque part à quoi sert la sécurité
sociale quels sont les réflexes que veut
avoir un cotisant et comment se
retrouver en fait dans cette grande
maison que la sécurité sociale et
l'insertion vers une activité économique
s'inscrit dans les compétences du
département chef de file d'une action
sociale
le challenge des créateurs permet à des
réunionnais de réaliser leur rêve est de
devenir leur propre patron
lors de l'édition 2014 si prix ont été
décernés les pâtissières ont reporté
celui de la création d'emplois bilan un
an plus tard a gagné le challenge des
créateurs la prix de la création
d'emplois pour nos propres emplois on a
créé
bleuse endroit précis et moi et puis
depuis on a encore créé plus d'emplois
puisque on a maintenant cinq salariés on
a une entreprise
de plus en plus de clientèle qui a un
problème de fabrication et de pointe
non
ok
du coup c'est jésus
si python créole a remporté le prix de
l'innovation le challenge des créateurs
a permis le développement de leur
entreprise et leur a apporté une grande
visibilité
le challenge est créateur on pense que
c'est un véritable tremplin pour les
jeunes entrepreneurs
ça apporte de la visibilité de la
crédibilité et un prix qui est
intéressant pour faire évoluer certains
projets ça a été le cas pour nous déjà
amélioré
oratoire on veut dire atelier de
fabrication de nos hôpitaux
on ne l'avait vraiment besoin on a pu
aménager le nouveau laboratoire on a pu
acheter du matériel également pourquoi
furent plus les inscriptions seront
ouvertes jusqu'au 13 novembre
après étude des dossiers les candidats
seront invités à un speed casting et
pourront ainsi défendre leurs projets
auprès du jury